when we speak about software
at least in polite company we tend to do
so in positive terms
we speak of what the software will do
the problems it will solve
the ways in which it will make our lives
easier
but the world is nowhere near that
simple is it
there's a duality to reality and so for
every thing our software does
there's something it doesn't do
for every problem it solves it creates
still others and if it makes our lives
easier in other ways it will make them
more
difficult
and this duality
this positive bias is embedded in what i
believe to be an archetypal story
something i've seen happen to other
people and something that has happened
to me
myself
it goes something like this
a team of software engineers spend weeks
or months building a software artifact
unit and integration testing it
and then finally
it's time for functional testing
it's time for a mock deployment
and so they start their program
it sinks into the darkness of the
terminal and in the background it races
on doing thousands or millions of
operations it was carefully programmed
to do
and after some amount of time
out of the darkness of that terminal
comes some output
the engineers doing the functional test
see it
error
no such file or directory
they look on in horror only milliseconds
before all of the precious context
needed to diagnose this failure was
resident in the program's memory
but now it's gone
leaving only this mocking error message
and then i come along to add insult to
injury
i come along to say this actually isn't
even that bad when we consider the
alternatives
because that program at least recognized
there was a failure
it didn't just careen on leaving the
mistake to be discovered hours or weeks
or months later
and it made some effort to tell us what
went wrong it at least gave us something
more than just error and a termination
and when terminating it didn't dump core
it didn't get a segmentation violation
and it didn't hang for 12 hours only for
some hapless system administrator to
wander by and see no output in the logs
and investigate further
no this example is actually better than
a lot of production programs
it's better than a lot of production
programs that i know of running in
production today
and this should give us pause
to give us occasion for reflection we
should step back and say maybe
we can do a bit better
so let's talk about the high level thing
that happened when we encountered the
failure the program ended
and there's nothing wrong with that
programs aren't humans they don't think
in fuzzy terms they can't go off and
divine how an environment should be
adjusted so they can perform their high
level task
they don't even really know their high
level task they just know some finite
set of operations
no there's no problem with terminating
but how do you get there
do you call something like abort or exit
or terminate or do you carefully
structure your application from the
lowest level to the highest level to
transmit that error context and then
only at the highest level do you make
the final decision to end the program
and i would pause it that latter
approach is much much better
i would pause it that exit and abort and
terminate are equivalent to things like
go-to and global variables that they
should be prescribed for the same
reasons
the reason we don't like goto is because
it introduces non-local control flow you
can no longer look at a small section of
code and determine all the ways in which
control can pass there through
it expands the amount of context you
need to keep in your mind to reason
about that code and therefore increases
the odds you'll make a mistake
and using exit or terminate or abort
does exactly this
if i look at a function signature how
can i tell that control cannot just flow
out through the return path or through
an exception but can also just suddenly
end my entire
program
global variables on the other hand we
don't like because they have non-local
effects
we can look at a function signature that
doesn't use globals and we can reason
about the possible set of effects it
could have by way of its parameters
if however we introduced global
variables to the mix it could go off and
it could mess with state in any one of a
number of different ways our ability to
reason about the code is destroyed
but exit and abort and terminate
don't just reach out and touch two or
three or four global variables
they reach out and they destroy every
single global variable
they destroy every single local variable
there is no piece of your program state
they don't destructively touch
in some sense a single call to abort or
exit or terminate destroys the entire
conception your program has of the whole
universe because the process apartment
rapidly collapses
and the alternative to this is something
that software engineers should love
being archetypally lazy as we are we
just kick the can down the road
when we're writing a very very narrowly
defined software component we don't have
information about how our user wants to
handle errors at the highest level we
don't know the proper high level action
to take and so we just don't make any
decision we kick the can down the road
we gather up the necessary context and
we make sure the next person up the
chain can make the decision in turn
distilled to a fundamental principle we
don't make assumptions about what our
user wants that are outside the
well-defined responsibility of the
component that we're writing we defer
those decisions and we let someone make
them
later
now that we have this principle let's
think about that error message no such
file or directory
and this isn't that bad of an error
message if all you know is enough it's a
pretty standard error message for eno
end no the problem with this error
message isn't what's in the string
it's what's not in the string
and when we think about enough we think
about the occasions in which we see that
error code we think there must have been
a call to syscall open it returned
negative one it said erno
and the application recognized this
error situation it grabbed erno's value
of enough and it propagated that but we
know that a call to open includes a path
it includes the vital piece of context
that could have helped us sort out what
went wrong in that first example
but that component made an assumption on
behalf of its users it expanded its
responsibility and decided that there
was no circumstance in which its caller
actually needed that context
and so it dropped us dropped it on the
floor and doomed us to the situation we
now find ourselves in
so armed with this principle let's talk
about integer parsing
let's talk about all the ways the
standard library gives us the parse
integers and let's examine why exactly
they fall on their face in the presence
of errors
the first function we're going to look
at is a to i and if you only think about
the success case of parsing integer if
you only think about strings that
actually represent integers the
signature of this function is perfect it
takes in a string and returns an integer
but if we pull out some type theory
and we think about the cardinality of
the string type and the cardinality of
the integer type there's a ridiculous
mismatch
there are far more strings than integers
and this suggests to us mathematically
that there are some strings that don't
represent integers
if you've ever written a book you know
this to be trivially true because your
entire book isn't just a string of
numbers
but 8i doesn't have a pathway for this
integers almost definitionally don't
have a not an integer representation and
indeed what a to i decides to do
is in this case to just return 0.
but a string can represent zero
it can just contain one character that's
zero
and so now our error case aliases a
valid case
context the function had to have
synthesized internally is wantonly
discarded we have no way to figure out
what happened
and reading the documentation for a to i
even more thoroughly it gets more
concerning because a to i just lively
skips leading white space and if it runs
into an end of a string of numbers
it just decides that's not a problem and
so if you feed a to i the string four
spaces followed by the number five and
then the word foxes
it says well that's just a valid
representation of five
but let's imagine we want to save 8i so
we put on our mysql developer hats and
we write a function called real eight i
one that wraps the return value in an
optional so we have a not an integer
representation
we go off and we call a to i and if it
returns something truthy if it doesn't
return zero we just return that great we
parse an integer we imagine for the
moment we're fine with leading white
space and we're fine with trailing
non-numeric parts
but what happens now
does this zero represent an error
or does it actually represent zero
and so what i do in the last half of
this function is i write a rudimentary
string parser that tries to figure out
if a string is an integer representing
zero
but that raises a philosophical question
what is the point of a to i
the point of a to i is to parse integers
it's to abstract that problem away so we
don't have to implement it
but if i want to use a to i in
some manner that approach is correct i
have to write an integer parser
and so i'm going to go ahead and pause
it that because of these deficiencies in
air reporting a to i is unsuited for any
use
so let's talk about sturdil
sturda l is an upgrade of a to i no
doubt it has more parameters and one of
them gives us a channel to pass
additional context back from the
function
the char double star stir end
ignoring for the moment that it's
woefully const incorrect it is starster
and is set to stir on error
so from outside we can observe whether
or not the string that was parsed was
actually an integer
but this raises another question
because is not an integer really the
only signal we want from this function
is it really the only context that it
synthesizes and becomes aware of in the
process of parsing an integer
or does it perhaps know
that the error was because the string
was fundamentally non-numeric
as opposed to being just too large to be
represented in the target type
and sturd l doesn't allow that
information to escape
but it does allow information to escape
about trailing non-numeric parts it uses
starstern to report the address of the
first non-numeric character
and so if this is an error to us we can
easily diagnose it
but it still just assumes that we don't
care about leading white space it gives
us no indication that there was leading
white space in the string that it parsed
four spaces and then five
and so we get to c plus plus 17
we get to from chars and now we actually
get a struct returned and the integer
imported through an out value so we can
support any type of integer
and when we look at a putter and an
ursey
in a struct it gives us hope that we're
going to get a lot of context out of
this function that we could even get the
context of where the parse failed
information that stirred l kept from us
because it needed to reserve starster
and equal stir for error
and indeed we do get through ec the
context that we complained about before
we get whether it failed due to an
overflow an invalid argument or was
actually successful
but unfortunately putter is mandated to
be set to first on failure which means
that we don't get any information out
about where the parse actually failed
information the function doubtless
synthesized internally
and from chars still skips leading white
space
which leads us to a refinement of our
principle
and that's that we should fail fast and
fail often if we're writing an integer
parsing routine all we need to do is
parse integers
if the users want to be able to trim
strings on the left because they're
dealing with user input
they probably have many different kinds
of user input they should probably be
implementing left trim as a standalone
function
us implementing it for them and
expanding our responsibilities
increasing the space that needs to be
tested of our function doesn't really
help
because left trim is easy to write and
anyone who wants it is probably going to
need to write it
anyway
but now we've taken a tour through these
three functions and the other thing that
we've seen is that they report errors in
very different ways
they have very different error
vocabularies
arguably eight i has no error vocabulary
and is therefore unsuited to any purpose
stir to l use a reserved value of an out
param and from chars is the most c like
it returns an enumerator that indicates
the exact class of failure that occurred
and this is not a bad way of reporting
errors
it's not bad to use some integer or
enumeration to report a code which
indicates the exact kind of failure
which occurred
many many c libraries do exactly this
all the way from posix to lip curl to my
sequel to openssl and many many
others but what happens when you want to
compose those components
what happens when you want to call out
to a posix function and a curl function
in the same function and report those
errors up to your caller with full
fidelity
and so we need something that can
combine together errors from multiple
sources
and so the standard gives us std error
code which not only contains an integer
but also contains a pointer to error
category some policy about how that
integer should be regarded
and two errors that are represented by
identical integers are deemed to be
non-equal if they have different
category pointers
which is a problem that is kind of
maligned and is one of the reasons why
they want to standardize status code the
idea that every category needs to be a
singleton makes you run into all kinds
of problems when you go to link
but this idea of having a fan in point
having a vocabulary type that can
represent any error
provided it's represented by an integer
as long as it comes from a category
raises yet another question
because when we were in the c-style
world and we got back an error we knew
exactly what category morally speaking
it was from
and so if we had some fallback we needed
to take if the error was no such file or
directory and we knew we were dealing
with posix errors we could just check
for enoend and if we were dealing with
curl errors we could check for curl e
file couldn't read file
but now we've established a vocabulary
type that decouples the caller and
callee from knowledge about how they're
communicating errors that makes those
integers in some sense opaque
and so how can we get this ability back
how can we gain back the ability to
diagnose broad classes of failure rather
than just identifying specific causes
and since we're computer scientists the
obvious answer is to just add another
level of indirection
to add a new type which is structurally
identical to stood error code containing
an int and a category pointer but which
is semantically very different
whereas stood error code is designed to
represent a very particular cause of
failure from a very particular component
stood error condition instead represents
very broad categories of failure you can
imagine an error code whose specific
cause of failure is i could not read the
tamil file the user provided on the
command line
but the broad class of failure that's a
part of is just no such file or
directory
and so error conditions and error codes
can be compared by way of the equivalent
member function of the associated
category
this equality allows for several error
codes to be identified as being no such
file or directory but perhaps less
obviously this goes the other way it's
easy to imagine several realizations of
no such file or directory what's more
difficult is to imagine an error code
that's a member of two broad classes of
error
until you consider that maybe an error
is both file not found and o error maybe
it represents that a file couldn't be
found but also that there was some
fundamental problem of the underlying i
o subsystem
so let's take a look at some code
let's try and implement our own error
enumeration that communicates our own
specific failure modalities and so of
course we define an enumeration with
four enumerators idiomatically the first
represents success and is given the
underlying value of zero this causes an
error code containing it to be falsy to
be able to be identified as success
then we need to write a make error code
function which can be found via adl
which accepts an enumerator and returns
an error code internally we use a
function local static to achieve the
singleton property that's required of
error categories
we give the error category a name which
allows us to identify the sub component
emitting this failure and then we
provide the message member function
something else that is not liked about
this function and that is
trying to be ameliorated in status code
is the fact that it exposes stood string
in an api and therefore requires you
include string and all of the allocator
machinery to use your c like error
reporting
but at any rate we cast the integer back
to a member of our enumeration we switch
over them and we return a human readable
description of that specific cause of
failure
which brings us to default error
condition which takes in one of our
specific failure modalities and
coalesces it to its broad class of
failure note that this is only
appropriate in the case where a code is
a member of one class of failure now all
of our non-success enumerators represent
invalid argument and so if the code is
truthy we just return stood ursy invalid
argument otherwise we return a default
constructed error condition which is
implicitly success
which brings us to those equivalent
functions that are used to establish
whether or not one of our error codes is
a member of a broad class of failure
but these are implemented by default in
the base class
and i've just pasted their default
implementations to show you that as long
as you implement default error condition
and as long as each of your codes is a
member of only one broad category of
failure you don't really need to provide
these functions
but here they are on the slide in case
one day you want to write an error code
that's both file not found and iowa
now that we've written our error
category we wrap up the enumerator cast
to an int and a reference to the
category in an error code and return it
as a quality of implementation detail we
open namespace stood we specialized is
error code enum for our enumeration type
we derive from truetype what this does
is this causes stood error code to be
implicitly constructable from
enumerators from our enumeration
which brings us to the last member of
this family which brings us to stood
system error which provides an exception
wrapper on top of an error code you
construct it with an error code and you
can now throw it as you would any other
exception
an idiom that i like to use in my code
is to not just throw stood system error
but to throw some type which is derived
from system error and which provides a
custom what function this allows me to
inject a very descriptive string with a
lot of context that can't be represented
in error code but also throw a system
error then whoever's up me on the call
stack can catch system error and if they
can handle error codes and want to
handle system error they can access that
context
but if they don't want to and that
exception is allowed to propagate all
the way up and is caught just as an
exception they can still call what and
not just get no such file or directory
but also
apps maybe get the name the file that
couldn't be found
which raises an interesting point
i've talked for a long time about error
handling and i haven't talked about
exceptions
what does our principle tell us about
when we should throw exceptions the
common wisdom of course is that
exceptions should be reserved for
exceptional situations
but how do you know a situation is
exceptional
who makes that decision
at what level of analysis
let's say i'm writing an xml parsing
routine
is invalid input exceptional
what if my user's using my xml parsing
routine to heuristically check the file
system to see if files are valid xml
with that added context maybe it's not
invalid xml that's exceptional but
rather valid xml
and so for most low-level components
exceptions aren't just unsuitable
because they introduce hidden control
flow they're not just unsuitable because
they have performance costs they're also
unsuitable because the decision to use
an exception indicates a decision about
the context in which your low-level
component will be used
but that kind of goes beyond
responsibility
component
so exceptions become more and more
appropriate as you move up through the
layers of your application as you take
and you combine more and more and more
functionality the strengths of
exceptions the fact that they allow for
you to write essentially branchless
looking code and the fact that they can
transport large amounts of heterogeneous
context comes into focus simultaneously
with the purpose of your application and
what is exceptional coming into focus
and so when i write code at the lowest
level i only traffic in error codes and
custom ad-hoc context only as i bring
together large pieces of my application
for testing do i start throwing
exceptions just to make my life a bit
easier
but now that we have an error vocabulary
now that we have a guiding principle
let's look at an error message from the
real world
let's say that a client opened a ticket
and said
a tag could not be parsed as an integer
what would you do
what would i do
i would probably immediately doubt my
code because no one wants to go to a
client and put their foot in their mouth
by accusing the client of being wrong
and so i might spend the whole afternoon
chasing down leads and writing new unit
tests and checking for some erroneous
emission of this error and only then
when i go back to the client
but what if i kept something from you
what if this isn't actually the whole
error message
what if instead the client opened a
ticket and said the system emitted this
error
would your response be the same
if if you worked in finance and you
understood the fix protocol maybe you
would just look at that buffer you'd
look at the carrot that it points to the
exact point of failure and you'd say
that uh that tag doesn't look like an
integer
5a isn't an integer the tag could not be
parsed as an integer and in five minutes
you'd reply to the client's ticket and
you'd say well one of your peers is
sending you invalid fixed messages
you get your whole afternoon back
and so how can we write code that allows
us to omit this kind of error message
how can we write a fixed message reader
well to write a fixed message reader we
need some way to get out fixed messages
and so we have a next function that
returns a non-owning pointer to a fixed
message and takes in an error code as an
out emitter this is a much maligned
idiom that may one day vanish when we
get stood expected but for now it's
idiomatic to return a value and pass in
an error code as a note parameter clear
it on success and set it to some error
code on failure
but that still just gets us
tagged could not be parsed as an integer
and so maybe we add another function
maybe we add a way to ask the fixed
message reader to format its last error
as a string we give it an opportunity to
emit some freeform context and that gets
us the error on the preceding slide
but we're making some assumptions about
how our user wants to use this component
aren't we
what if our user doesn't want to just
format the last error what if they have
some programmatic way of remediating the
last error and they want to examine the
context thereof
or what if the user just doesn't like
our error message format
why is format last error privileged as a
member poking around in private data and
using it to format one particular
realization of the context generated by
the parse
and so we fix this we fix this by just
adding getters so that we can get the
state left over by the last parse
we take our format last error function
and instead of making the ground source
of truth about failures we just make it
a convenience function we imagine most
of our clients want an easy turn key way
to format their last error and so we
give them one
but we don't access any private data
from inside there we go through the
public interface
and so if our clients decide that they
don't want error messages or they want a
different format they can get it
but a fixed connection does way more
than just parsefix messages it has a
socket it needs to maintain some timers
it has a fixed log there's a lot of
different components there so how can we
keep error context moving upward through
the stack how can we propagate error
context through a fixed client
obviously we can provide a stood string
getter that returns a formatted error
but now we're back running a foul of our
principle again
we're making assumptions about our
user's use case
and so what we need to do is we need to
give the user some way to establish
which particular sub-component generated
the last failure we need to provide them
some way to be able to go through the
sub components decide which errors they
care and don't care about and maybe
implement format last error for
themselves
and so we do exactly that we have an
enumeration of sources of the last error
we allow the user to retrieve it and
then we give them getters for sub
components so if they see the last
failure with a parse failure they can
grab the fixed message reader and they
can inspect it to decide what they want
to do next
which brings us pretty close to the
highest level of our application
we've parsed integers we've written a
fixed message reader and now we've
brought it all together with a fixed
connection
but as we approach the highest level of
an application we run into a problem and
that problem is multi-threading
because previously we were discussing
things in the context of a caller call e
relationship we assumed there was some
way to transmit information back up the
stack about the errors that occurred
but when you're in a stood thread
there's no one above you on the call
stack if you return the thread just ends
and the rest of your system goes off
running happily
and i'm sure that's a failure modality
that a lot of people have seen when
errors are generated in multi-threaded
programs
no instead you need some way to
coordinate threads to coordinate work to
detect errors to fan those errors in to
shut the threads down and only then
re-emit the failure
and for this reason along with other
reasons i like to say something about
multi-threaded programs and that's that
they're easy to get started
but they're really hard to stop
so let's take a look at a component that
can manage a pool of threads
let's write a thread pool
it has a state and we've decided we're
going to use i o context from azo to
manage the work queue that's not really
what we're concerned about anyway we're
concerned about that high level error
handling and each state has a thread the
worker thread that's servicing it and
internally we keep a list of these
states and we have a mutex and we have
an exception putter to fan in the error
and then we have a constructor that
determines the number of threads and we
can call run surrender the foreground
thread in a blocking way and run all of
the execution context by spinning up
some background threads
then we have a stop function that we can
call both nullery and unary if we call
it nullery it just asks the threadpool
to shut down gracefully to stop all the
workers and surrender control back to us
from run
but if we pass in an exception putter it
actually becomes a way for us to
integrate external components we have an
external component that encounters some
failure we can call stop with that
failure and that will cause the thread
pool to collapse re-emit that failure
and serve as a fan endpoint for our
entire application
then since we want to be able to
actually distribute work to this thing
we have a begin an end iterator across
the states so we can do that
but just looking at an interface doesn't
really help you write code that's
complicated it doesn't help you solve
all of the sharp edges involved in
spinning up some threads and then
fanning them back in correctly without
leaking anything or leaving it on the
floor so let's actually write that run
function the first thing we're going to
do to help ourselves along is we're
going to write a lambda run which takes
in an execution context and tries to run
it and if running it fails by throwing
an exception we ask the rest of the
thread pool to stop we give them the
exception that we emitted we caused them
to fan in all the other threads and emit
that exception
then we enter an anonymous scope we grab
an iterator to our first date and we
bump it by one
and the reason we bump it by one is
because the foreground thread is going
to be surrendered it's going to run that
first context and so we don't need to
make a worker thread for it
then we go off and we create an
anonymous scope guard we create an
anonymous scope guard to work around the
fact that thread creation can actually
fail thread creation being one of these
operations that a lot of people think of
as always succeeding but which can
actually fail you can create two worker
threads and then try and create a third
and an exception gets thrown and if
you're not careful control will leave
your function and two worker threads are
running and some others aren't and who
knows what that's going to run off and
do to the state of your application
and so inside of our scope guard we grab
the first iterator and bump it by one
again and then we loop only up to the
point to which we've created threads
because we don't want to deal with the
thread that failed to be created we loop
up and we stop exactly where the outer
loop got to for each thread we visit we
ask its execution context to stop we
join the thread to make sure it's not
off mucking with program state when we
don't think it is and we fall off the
end of the structure thereby ensuring
that no matter how we leave this
anonymous scope we've introduced all of
the threads will be fanned in and ended
then we just continue looping across our
states we spawn threads and we pass them
a lambda which just calls our run
function note that we're very careful to
capture the begin iterator by value
because the last thing we want to do is
introduce a race between the thread and
the loop that is spawning the threads
then of course we turn to the foreground
thread we ask it to run the first
context and everything goes off and runs
once control leaves all those run
functions once we run the destructor
when we hit that all powerful closing
curly brace
all the threads have been spun down
they've all stopped and we've gathered
the error context from the first one
that failed through our stop member
function
all that leaves for us to do is acquire
a lock
examine the exception putter and if it's
truthy we re-emit that failure we
teleported it from whichever threat
experienced the failure back to the one
which was below main
we threw it and now our user can catch
it and write it out to their user in
turn
which is the highest level of the
application right
we finally brought everything together
we finally fanned in and managed all of
the error context
but let's think about another error let
me show you another error that i've seen
actually at work one that recently
caused consternation i wrote a network
server it emits log messages like this
when the connection experiences some
failure this one failed because it
couldn't read from the socket because
the socket was at the end of the file
a client had an issue with this system
and a member of the operations team went
off and was going through logs trying to
sort out what was wrong and saw all
these failures and came to me and said
it says here there's a failure is this
actually a problem
and i having written many network
programs like no no the connection just
reached the end and we shut it down we
reaped it it's fine client connections
go away
and so the member of the operations team
was able to go off and actually sort out
the client issue but when i was
preparing this talk i thought about this
failure
because this really raises an important
question in error handling and reporting
and that is
whose error
an error to who
because in our previous situation
read the low-level system call
does not regard end-to-file as an error
it clears erno and it returns zero and
it reads no bytes that's perfectly
acceptable
but at a higher level of analysis
let's say we want to write a component
that deals with partial reads and so we
want to request exactly 16 bytes be read
at that level of analysis all of a
sudden reading three bytes and running
into end to file is a big problem
that success case to read is now an
error to your operation
but then as we reach the highest levels
of analysis if we reach the layer of the
server where it's coordinating all the
client connections it doesn't really
care
that the connection reached into file
it's gonna do it's just gonna tear it
down
reap it and
accept all the other connections that
come in
which brings us to a situation where
succeed failed do we really care
at the highest level of a tcp server if
a connection from a client fails does it
matter
what would it mean for that to succeed
what does it mean if your tcp connection
gets to the end of its run and it
succeeded does that mean that the
connection wasn't reset that you didn't
reach end of file how can that actually
happen
and so at some level of analysis we need
to reach a point where we have
sufficient context to look at failures
to look at errors and say this doesn't
really matter
this only matters to the sub component
that emitted it it doesn't matter to my
broader system or we need to check it
and see if it's part of a specific
failure modality and then make that
decision
but the thread pool that we just wrote
that we were going to use to manage all
of the work at the highest level of our
application
it deems every single failure
to be utterly terminal and critical
if any piece of work throws an exception
and that exception is caught immediately
that's the whole thread pull down
there's no seam for us to inject
intelligence about which errors actually
matter to us there's no way for us to
keep the system running when we want to
ignore a failure
which means we need to take a different
approach so let's take a look at a piece
of code
that my company uses
let's take a look at a processor manager
purpose of this processor manager is to
coordinate devices which are receiving
raw packets and feeds which are
processing those parsing them and
emitting market data messages downstream
to do this it spins up some background
worker threads as dictated by the
processor manager settings which aren't
relevant to this presentation
we have a start function which starts
the background threads and we have a
stop function which fans them in and
shuts them down
but that's not really a lot of
information to go by we call start and
the background threads are running but
are they still running have they failed
is all of the work done
when should i call stop
and so we inject a callback
we inject some user customizable
component which can receive events
emitted by the system and then reach
back into the processor manager and
according to its own rules
the processor manager callback looks
like this it has four events for device
processor and packet processor begin and
end with a device processor thread being
one that reads packets and a packet
processor thread being one that actually
provides a context to process them our
begin and end events both actually have
a reference to the particular sub
component which is generating the event
we give the user that context so they
can decide how to handle things
but that's not all the context we have
available because when those threads
reach their end there's going to be some
reason they reach the end maybe it's
success maybe it's failure but that
thread will have that context available
and so we provide a pathway for passing
that through as the threads end
we give all the context to the user
and then we allow the user to implement
only their concerns they implement only
their logic around when the processor
manager should start and stop which
failures should be good and properly
terminal
that allows us to write something that
looks like this something that i
actually wrote recently for a project a
processor manager callback designed to
handle endofile specifically
because while some devices go off and
read from nyx which is a theoretically
unbounded stream of incoming packets
some devices actually are backed by
pcapp files and pcapp files are very
well deleted they have an actual end
and when they reach an end and you try
and read a packet from them you get an
end to file error
it causes their associated device thread
to end in error
and so inside this processor manager
callback realization inside the event
handling i check for end of file and if
end of file is the error rather than
shutting the whole processor manager
down and causing the application to fail
instead i wait for all of the other
device processors to also end with end
of file and then when the last of those
ends and end to file i go off to each of
the packet processors and i wait for it
to flush its queue
and then once i'm all of the market data
has been processed downstream only then
do i allow the run to end
and to answer the questions about start
and stop and how do we know when we're
done i have a weight member function
that the person who started the
processor manager can call which will
block the foreground thread until the
processor manager run is finished
according to the definition that i've
injected where end of file causes
successful end and errors cause an
unsuccessful end then once they've
returned from wait they can go off and
they can ask me if i end it due to end
of file and if i return true they can be
happy and the application can succeed
otherwise they call maybe throw they go
into the callback and they scrape out
all of the contacts that i save and they
throw it as an exception it gets fanned
in from whichever thread generated it
saved rethrown caught in main and
finally logged to the user
which brings us to the two stragglers in
this formulation
which brings us to warnings and logging
two things that trigger people into this
kind of special pleading where they give
the principles of software engineering a
run around
i don't have a channel warnings and so
i'm just gonna dump them to the standard
output stream
but the problem with that is that even
more so than errors the idea of a
warning contains embedded in it the idea
that you need context to decide how to
handle it because if it was always a
failure it would just be an error the
fact that you've deemed that it's a
warning means that you know it's not an
issue to some callers and by reaching
out to global state and just writing to
standard out what you've done is you've
told those callers that you always think
that's worth showing to their users
you've made it very difficult for them
to embed your component in their
component cleanly
you've widened the responsibilities of
your component unnecessarily and in so
doing you've reduced the number of
circumstances in which it can be used
and so even if it's difficult even if it
involves restructuring code warnings
need a proper channel
and the same kind of analysis applies to
logging people love to use logging as
the run around on the prescription
against global state i need a global
logger
but what if your user doesn't want any
logging output what if your user doesn't
want certain classes of things to be
logged what if your user wants two
different components to log in two
different ways
and you may try and give this the run
around and say okay well i'll inject a
logger but again what if the user
doesn't like all the things you log what
if the user doesn't like your logging
format what if the user wanted to react
to those events by not even logging at
all
because what your component was actually
doing when it was writing to the log
wasn't writing to the log that was just
something you did expanding your
responsibilities to fulfill a particular
use case
your component was emitting events
and so you need to reify those in
something that can handle events
an observer
and then you expose your client to the
fullest context that your subcomponent
generates not only that but if you want
to be truly nice you can go off and you
can implement a realization of that
interface that just does the logging you
want it to do anyway you can have your
cake and you can eat it too
so as you leave this talk what should
your takeaways be
well the first one is to not assume that
stud threads constructor doesn't throw
to not assume that that will never
happen integers can overflow stood
threads constructor can throw and malik
can return no
don't throw away potentially useful
context don't assume that because you
carefully and painstakingly synthesized
information that some failure makes it
totally irrelevant to your user
and remember that guiding principle to
not make assumptions on behalf of your
user to not broaden the responsibilities
of your components and thereby limit the
use cases to which they appertain
because maybe if you follow these
principles
one day it'll be the difference between
this error message
and your phone ringing at 2 am
and this one and the operations team
being able to do their job and let you
sleep
are there any questions
[Applause]
a lot of what you suggested sort of
hinges around the idea of being able to
pass a context through things pretty
cleanly
do you have suggestions for how to get
there from the system that doesn't
already have that
so the question i was asked to repeat
questions the question was about um a
lot of the stuff i talked about assumes
that we can transmit context what would
i do in systems that don't have the
ability to transmit that context
and so what i would say there's a couple
different scenarios that i found myself
in that situation so there's one where
there's like good and truly no path
through and in that case you're either
stuck with
breaking the rules on either side
because the person you're going through
broke the rules or you're you're stuck
with trying to create
back channels right like so you know you
might they might allow you to pass
through a void star and you might use
that that's the lowest hanging fruit on
the other side there may be some way for
you to ferret information away in like
something that approaches a global like
a thread local or an actual global and
then you use that in a very tightly
defined subsystem that interacts only
with that component
that's something that i've done quite a
bit you know you have this badly behaved
piece of code but you really need to use
it and so you write a lot of badly
behaved code around it and then you seal
it off right like so for example in the
logging example i work with a lot of
code that just goes off and globally
writes to the log and i had a piece of
code i wrote once that wanted to walk
over like a bunch of different feeds and
if it couldn't initialize them it was
like that's fine i just don't run that
feed but this just spat hundreds of
lines of error logs out to the log for
no reason and so what i had to do was i
had to write a component that went into
the global logger and disabled it for a
bit and then re-enabled it and then i
sealed that in something that i could
test and build confidence in and then i
could build the rest of my software
properly and i think that's a fairly
standard approach to take when you're
interoperating with a legacy system
that's just not well behaved you need to
either give it a run around or you need
to break your own rules and try and just
constrain where you're breaking the
rules because too often people like oh i
need to break the rules here i get to
break them everywhere
so i hope that's an answer to the
question
there's a question from online
uh there's a question
um stood expected was briefly mentioned
at the beginning of the talk how does
this approach to error handling change
with the inclusion inclusion of such a
library there is also tl expected
which is widely used yeah so the
question is about expected and i briefly
mentioned it um i think it just helps us
do away with that that idiom that people
don't like where you pass in the error
code as an out parameter and the reason
people don't like that is because it
requires
the thing you return to have some
reserved value that you can return even
in success cases for pointers it's
obviously null and for integers it's
obviously zero but when you get to more
complicated code the idea that you need
to return something to report your error
through an outparameter is not good and
expected just solves that problem by
eliminating that entire idiom
so you had a question in the front
uh
so
we used to build a login
logic people automatically will print
out the thread id
in the file name
and the line number
so
that kind of like a lobby it will keep
like
some
status of the program and when there is
an error it also log
when id the file name in the line
yeah so the comment about that was that
in a lot of instances you want to kind
of get a trace of where the program went
and then when you have a failure you
have like a lot of information not just
about where the failure occurred but
what led up to it
that's accurate so one thing that i've
that you can you can usually do i mean
you can do that right like you could
have some context you pass around that
records what's happening right like you
inject it and it writes down where it's
been that's one approach the other
approach that i've found and that
actually leads to this error message
this error message comes from something
that captures a lot of context for
what's happening is that if you can
identify
with the high level context that i've
talked about through the whole talk if
you can identify the critical moments
where like there's going to be a failure
and there's some opportunity to emit
information about it then you can fan
out from that in your analysis of all
the components you're building that lead
into that and you can make sure they
give you back enough information right
so for example this error message is
emitted um in response to a client query
that fails right and so you can see that
whatever s3 component we have in the
back end has reported its error and it
gets logged out with the domain the the
name of the category but other things
like the identifier of the file in the
database that was being acted on are
reported and from a very high level it's
not obvious how that context could be
captured because the database is very
well abstracted but when i was writing
that component or thinking about that
component i thought to myself well
knowing what part of the database was
being acted on is very very important in
that instance and so when i was
designing the database interop component
that abstracts the whole database away
to like in it run it has this getter to
get out the last identifier right to
make sure that information can be
written down and then i leverage source
location to get the file in the line so
to generate this error message i call a
function that takes a source location
and then if you know
everything else fails and i actually
want to understand where in the code it
came from i can at least go to that
source location but if you wanted like a
stack trace you'd be left getting a back
trace which involves operating system
specific magic and compiler flags or you
could pass around a context that you can
append things to right like you can say
i was here i was here i was here and
then eventually you can either dump that
or not
yes
in the back
so the comment is that we'll get stack
trace which addresses what i was just
saying and also we expect to get
expected i think the pun might have been
intended okay in uh in 23 so that'll
that'll help i mean i i've written code
with expected and i really like it it
just has never gotten standardized and
so
i keep end up using the standard idioms
yeah so yeah the comment is it's in the
last steps so
oh there's a question in the back
but
even having the option to capture
context around or forward errors in the
case where an error is determination as
overhead
or capturing context in the case of
something like apy
about
right so the comment is about the fact
that uh propagating and capturing
context also has a cost and that cost
can be borne by the success path as well
as the disappointment or failure path
the way that i i tend to work around
that is that so in that case right like
what i think that might be an argument
for is an expansion of the
responsibility of a component right like
let's say that i want to write an
integer parser but i want to marry into
it the idea that transmitting
information about where the failure
occurred is a non-starter because i'm
using cmd instructions for example and
so then you you'd write that but you'd
have full awareness of that fact it
wouldn't just be a general purpose
utility that falls on its face for no
reason like a to i is and i've done that
in in code like there's error context
you throw away because you actually know
from the embedding it's never needed and
if you were to preserve it you'd you
know you'd end up allocating a string
and i don't want to allocate a string
every time i build up some context
because i want to be sparse with my
allocations um what i'm more getting at
is in a lot of instances writing down
the context is really cheap right
especially making it available
programmatically it might be a few
pointers um it might just be allowing
your user to inject the storage you use
and leaving that behind like rather than
me newing up a string buffer and writing
my path and that then throwing it away
when open fails it's like you give me a
path i fill it i try and open it if that
fails you still have the buffer and you
can you can totally throw that away so
are there any other questions
okay that looks like it thank you very
much
[Applause]
you